pour tout le monde ou presque se
passionner pour les dinosaures est un
loisir une lubie voire même une perte de
temps une chose futile et infantile qui
bien souvent passe avec l'âge mais elles
sont aussi bizarre d'être admiratif
devant les êtres les plus étonnants et
les plus impressionnants que notre terre
ait porté de mes attaches l'expliquent
les dinosaures c'est trop pour les
diamants mais je le dis dans ce jeu de
crier mais je ne sais pas je dis pas ça
que parce que j'ai un dinosaure en
plastique sais pas mais si vous dites ça
c'est certainement vous ne savez pas
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec un jouet
dinosaures vous croyez pas que je peux
faire de la science avec un jouet t-rex
défi relevé
tenez vous savez comment decima mas de
dinosaures et bien grâce à ce petit
jouet en plastique je peux vous donner
la basse du plus tard réussir leurs
prédateurs que la terre ait jamais
portés quijano zaurus rex au travers les
t-rex des encore le tyrannosaure bah
quoi vous pensiez peut-être que pour
estimer la menace d'un t-rex il fallait
poser coc ça eh bien vous n'y êtes pas
du tout blague à part les autres
fossilisés sur son très lentement
transformer en pierre ce qui fait que
leur poids actuel n'a plus rien à voir
avec celui de l'eau ce qu'ils furent
jadis une tomme de véhicules en plus sur
les os fossilisés il manque et les
muscles et la commune se content quand
même
alors eh bien nous divise et figurines
car cette figurine n'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une maquette à l'échelle 1 30e
d'un authentique tyrannosaures et comme
elle semble pas trop mal réussi dans la
foi on peut peut-être partir du principe
qu'il s'agit d'un véritable tyrannosaure
mais en prendre trois buts
alors d'abord
manche 1 pour faire semblant de savoir
ce que je fais ce fait très beau et je
remplis avec leur pouvant contenir le
monde sireix plus car à bordeaux
j'aime ce récipient il est bon et dur un
peu commun comme à un cours de math
n'est ce pas je disais donc arts à
bordeaux et j neige le t-rex dedans en
faisant bien attention que tout me qui
déborde retourne dans une coupelle le
volume d'eau qui correspond à la
maquette s'écoule alors à l'intérieur de
la coupelle je pèse ensuite l'eau à
l'intérieur de la boîte mail elle
contient 260 grammes d'eau soit 0,26 kg
en partant du principe que le corps d'un
t-rex à peu près comme le nôtre et elle
est composée à 80% d'eau il n'est pas
déraisonnable de penser qu un t-rex de
cette taille en chair et en os au
préposé l'équivalent de son poids en eau
c'est à dire 0,26 kg ou rennes on est
d'accord mais le coeur c'est pas qe2
comme tu fais quoi les 20% qui restent à
l'esj accordait cette question les van
sant qui reste se partage entre loos
plus dense que l'eau et la grèce plus
les bières que l'eau il faut aussi tenir
compte de l'air contenu dans les poumons
ce qui fait qu'en moyenne les densités
de tous ces ingrédients se compensent
les uns les autres et équivalent la
densité de l'eau et ça se vérifie très
bien en pratique par exemple chez à
cocody de la densité moyenne du corps
est égal à 1 kg par litre c'est à dire
exactement celle de l'eau dont il ne
reste plus qu'à ramener notre modèle
réduit de tyrannosaure à l'échelle 1 30e
à sa taille grandeur nature c'est à dire
à peu près une douzaine de mètres
pour cela il faut agir et non 30 ça
aurait été si notre t-rex avait été tout
plat mais ce n'est pas une crêpe
il est en volume il faut donc multiplié
par 30 dans les trois dimensions de
l'espace 30 x 30 x 30 étaient bien là 30
occupe c'est à dire 27 mille images sa
pub on bénit pour moi ça pour obtenir
volume
irex un véritable tir expliquerait donc
0 26 kg x 27000 c'est-à-dire 7000 vague
kg cet homme où l'homme se fait beaucoup
de mal
ben justement tu as dit que tu basé sur
la densité des crocodiles qui était de 1
kg lanta il me semble or le crocodile
eux je crois que c'est pas le plus
proche parent du t-rex le plus proche
tancé les oiseaux faudrait pas de tenir
compte du fait qu'il avait les autres et
que du coup ça alléger considérablement
le poids de son squelette non oui c'est
vrai que même si ça m'ennuie de la m tu
as raison à cause ou plutôt grâce à
leurs sacs aérien qui pénètre jusqu'à
l'intérieur de l'arceau les oiseaux
d'une densité moyenne qui est inférieure
à celle des autres animaux d'environ 0,7
kg par litre au lieu de 1 kg par litre
on sait par ailleurs que le t-rex
posséder de tels sacs zai rien puisque
la première vertèbre de t-rex jamais
déterré a été nommé manosque on dilue
gigas ce qui veut dire grosso berthelot
spongieuse et ce bien avant que le nom
de tyrannosaurus rex soit à l'antenne
par les cinq le stage de redire à tirer
il serait du simple et bob l'eponge cet
aspect spongieux lui vient de ce que les
autres chez le t-rex comme chez les
oiseaux actuels sont creux et ils sont
remplis n'ont pas de moelle osseuse mais
de ramification des poumons qui
envahissent les hausses à l'intérieur du
corps tout entier et allège
considérablement le poids du squelette
et donc le poids du corps en général
pour tenir compte de l'effet de ces cinq
aerial il nous faut donc multiplier le
poids du t-rex
donc c'est cet homme par 0.7 c'est à
dire la densité des oiseaux actuels et
alors on obtient une masse de 4,9 tonnes
c'est
hier deux tonnes de moins 5 tonnes c'est
à peu près le poids d'un éléphant d'asie
alors que le pjak c'était deux fois plus
long est deux fois plus gros et oui
c'est important de tenir compte du fait
que les dinosaures sont plus proches des
oiseaux que des crocos alors pourquoi je
garde ce havre par exemple on pensait
autrefois que brachiosaures en fait j
rafati temps peser 80 tonnes c'était
inimaginable
c'est pourquoi il était présenté dans
l'eau le seul endroit où il pouvait
selon les paléontologues de l'époque
soutenir de son propre poids avant
j'étais un godillot
mais ça c'était avant qu'on tienne
compte du fait que les os du
brachiosaure son creux aujourd'hui les
estimations tournent totaux de 20 à 30
tonnes un poids parfaitement supportable
par les membres trois soupes corps comme
des piliers du brachiosaure et le voici
le secret du gigantisme des dinosaures
des eaux creux est extrêmement léger et
des membres droit sous le corps
soutenant le poids de l'animal comme des
colonnes des membres par ailleurs très
différents de ceux des crocodiles située
sur le côté ça allait aussi le fait que
les dinosaures contrairement aux
mammifères pondent des oeufs
bah oui imaginez un diplodocus survivre
par an plus de cinq ans enceinte
jusqu'aux yeux
mais revenons à nos moutons aux russes
avec la même technique de diversion on
peut aussi mesurer le poids de godzilla
bon je n'ai pas de figurine de gosier
mais bon on va mettre que mentir à nous
offrent à la faire le nouveau godzilla
de 2014 mesure une centaine de mètres de
long soit à peu près 300 fois la taille
de ma figurine pour la remise à
l'échelle du poison obtenu tout à
l'heure il ne me fera pas multiplier 260
grammes par 30 au cube mais par 300
reculent et ça me donne plus 7000 20
kilos mais 7020 tonnes bon là même
mais tant que godzilla est un dinosaure
et qu'il a des sacs aérien 7020 tonnes
ça fait quand même beaucoup
cette technique je vous en fait cadeau à
laquelle le monde ne connaît plus de
frontières vous pouvez mesurer le poids
de n'importe quoi sans l'aide de malange
géantes comme le poids de la tour eiffel
canadienne ou bien encore de l'étoile
noire
il vous suffit pour cela de quelques
récipient un peu d'eau une balance de
cuisine d'un modèle réduit de votre
choix et de connaître la densité du
matériau dos aux copains original
les possibilités sont pour ainsi dire
infinie